al amparo de la noche los trabajadores
retiran el pilar de la vergüenza una
escultura de unos 8 m compuesta por
cuerpos retorcidos y 50 rostros
angustiados representa los asesinatos de
partidarios de la democracia en la plaza
Tiananmen en 1989
el jueves por la mañana a los
estudiantes y espectadores de la
Universidad de Hong Kong intentan
vislumbrar el lugar donde una vez estuvo
la estatua
no creo que la gente espera que esto
suceda en la universidad supuestamente
con mayor libertad de expresión ellos
intentaron convertirse en los primeros
en eliminar todas las historias todas
las partes de la historia dentro del
campus
la pieza fue erigida en 1997 el último
año de la ocupación británica de Hong
Kong durante años simboliza una amplia
gama de libertades a diferencia de China
continental donde los eventos de
Tiananmen se han borrado en gran medida
la Universidad Tito razones legales para
el desmantelamiento de la estatua
durante los últimos 2 años Beijing ha
tomado medidas enérgicas contra las
manifestaciones a favor de la democracia
en Hong Kong según la ley de seguridad
que otorga China la capacidad de
intervenir y frenar las protestas del
discurso varios líderes prodemocracia y
organizadores de las conmemoraciones de
Tiananmen han sido arrestados en el
pasado las vigilias atraían a decenas de
miles en Hong Kong